hello everyone thanks for choosing to
join this talk I'm Nicola I work at
Airbnb for the machine
structure team and I work on this
particular thing called zipline which is
a feature engineering framework for
declaratively generating features so we
will that's a lot of big words we'll
unpack that slowly throughout the
presentation so a little bit of a
context before we jump into the problem
statement here I'll wait for the new
people to settle down so what I'm going
to present here is not just my work
unlike many of the other talks so work
of a lot of other engineers who build
this thing called big head witches and
n2n machine learning platform and this
is in the context of supervised machine
learning which means your training over
data which already has labels oops and
we are going to talk about specifically
structured data not unstructured data
what I mean by that is the kind of data
that lives in databases and flows
through logs not audio or text or media
right and most of this talk is going to
be about an algorithm for efficiently
generating features right so let's zoom
out a little bit and look at how
supervising supervising machine learning
is done today in the industry so a data
scientist starts with a problem right
and then he explodes data that is
available to him within the company
right the database is the service logs
the data legs whatnot goes about
creating a feature or set of features
that he can use to train a model and he
keeps doing this in a loop until the
model is deemed good enough right and
once it's deemed good enough the data
scientist tried to tries to
productionize this and wire it up to an
application server so I have been using
data scientist as a singular term here
usually this is teams of people with
different kinds of skill sets so the
first set of skills is data engineering
like creating the pipelines that is
necessary to generate features and the
data scientist which is the fancy ml PhD
who goes about training the model with
the newest algorithm and the next set of
people who take this to production or
what in industry are called machine
learning engineers but in reality
they're systems engineers and I think
machine learning engineers as a fancy
marketing term to you know hire more
people well so we just looked at the
flow and I think there is more to
machine learning in industry than just
the modeling part itself so by some
accounts about 5% of what you actually
do is going to be core machine learning
the maths and about 95 percent or at
least 95 percent is the actual systems
engineering that is required to put
together a model in production right
this is from a paper by scallion nips so
what's the goal of bighead here the goal
is can we eliminate the glue code or
automate it somehow and allow for a
single data scientist to be able to take
a machine learning model into production
right so this is a fairly imperative
process in the sense that you need to
basically spell out what you need to do
throughout the workflow instead of
declaring a specification so to really
enable a data scientist to take an idea
into production this needs to be
declarative to some extent in the sense
that the data scientist needs to be able
to say this is what needs to be done
instead of how to do it we will see more
details about that later
and this is also very expensive in the
sense that all this gluing together is
what makes this whole project take about
six months to a year instead of days the
declaration in the data scientist head
is fairly small actually
right so there is another problem here
which is the coupling with the
application servers so there is a subtle
difference from the last set of images
to this one which basically the
difference here is that there is this
new thing called key that is flowing
between features serving and application
servings so let's say you're trying to
predict weather in st. Louis right the
question here is really simple and the
question doesn't really care about the
signals that go into predicting weather
right so in this case the key is the
city or st. Louis in itself so the idea
here is that we want to minimize the
surface of contracts between
applications and the machine learning
system all right now this is the broader
context let's jump into future
engineering so a big part of the time
that is spent in a machine learning
project is facial engineering or
converting your raw data into meaningful
features and by our accounts are by our
analysis it's 60 to 70 percent and this
is really important because there is a
saying which basically goes like a good
data with an oaky model always beats a
fancy model with mediocre data I don't
have much proof to back that that 60 to
70% number up except for this one
question from the Google machine
learning course which basically says you
spend more than half your time doing
feature engineering for machine learning
so what makes this take so long and why
is this process so hard and why is this
so dreaded by a data scientist and why
does no one want to do it so I think the
real thing that academia doesn't deal
with is that everything in this workflow
keeps changing and in the sense that
features and the future declarations
themselves and the algorithm that is
used to train the model keeps changing
and as the world changes you see more
data so if users are taking
actions on your application or if there
is new sensor data that's flowing
through your sensors there will be new
data and your model needs to incorporate
the understanding of the new boy right
so this is good it helps your model be
performant but dealing with change is
really really hard so there are two
problems really here the first problem
is a release engineering problem
so usually when you talk about release
engineering you generally think about a
first order function so what I mean by
that is you're taking a function that is
written by application developers to
handle data and convert that into
actions but machine learning is a bit
peculiar in the sense that it is an
algorithm that is actually generating a
function which is a first order function
so it's consuming label data and
generating a function which takes on
label data and makes predictions this
talk is not going to be about this for
the rest of the presentation we will
jump into the second problem which is
dealing with changing data so first an
example I choose a problem that I can
easily solve or I have the intuition
which is predicting if you're going to
get Indian food tonight right one of the
intuitions is that hot weather and hot
food don't go well together so maybe the
average temperature between now and
before dinner is a signal all right and
or maybe people who are into Indian food
behave a little bit like addicts in the
sense that it's a habit it's a behavior
so maybe we can look at the signal that
how many times did you have Indian food
last year or maybe you're new you
haven't tried Indian food yet but if
you're already tolerant to spicy or if
you have certain masochistic tendencies
you're willing to give in in food a
short so maybe one of the other signals
is the amount of spice you can tolerate
or the spiciest food you have had in the
last year right so all these features
that I described here change
with time so if I were to put this in a
time line I am trying to predict whether
you are going to have Indian food now
and at some point in the future
at 8 o'clock maybe I will see a label
whether you had an Indian you had Indian
food for dinner or not so and the
feature values also keep changing
throughout this time right now the first
set of things we need to look at here is
what are the freshest features available
what I mean by that is you don't want to
pick feature values from the future or
from the right side of this dotted line
because you know your model is going to
perform really well when you train it
but in production it won't materialize
and you don't want this feature values
to be far towards the left either which
means your training over stale data
right so you want them to be as precise
as possible but no more precise all
right
similarly if you have a set if you try
to make a prediction at a later point in
time maybe in an hour where you have
thought sufficiently about Indian food
and made up your mind to actually have
it there's going to be a second set of
features and a second row for training
your date a second row of training data
right now if you look at this problem
closely right this is some sort of a
joint a time series joined specifically
right and a time series join over
aggregating data which is the facial
definitions that we saw before now
Before we jump into the algorithm itself
let's take a step back and understand a
few properties about aggregations right
so aggregation math is basically math
about maps let's take a simple example
to start with its sum and sum is what's
called commutative in the sense that you
can sum over any order of the elements
alright so what this means is you don't
have to use an expensive sorting step
before you are get your data and the
other property is that it is associative
so you can arbitrarily split your data
across nodes and combine the sums
together later the other property is
reversibility we
means you can reverse data off of
aggregations it's not very intuitive why
this would be useful but we'll see
shortly throughout the presentation and
this makes some what's called an abelian
group there are other properties but
they are not of interest for this
presentation now a question to the
audience how many of you think that
average also has the same properties how
many of you think it doesn't alright so
there is a not very clever trick which
is changing the data itself that you
operate on to make this an abelian group
which basically means you factor the
aggregate into sum and account and then
aggregate over that instead of
maintaining the average itself and you
finalize with a division alright so you
can lift a nugget average into something
that's an abelian group with
reversibility alright so by our
definition an aggregation is something
that has an IR which is bounded in terms
of memory or you can keep the entire
history of events that happen which will
grow unbounded li but it won't yield
towards optimization and there are two
classes of aggregations the first class
is what we just discussed some average
and count and then there is another
class of aggregations which is minimum
maximum a few sketches that counts
different other metrics so there is a
very subtle difference between these two
remember that I said reversibility is
important and reversibility is what
distinguishes these two classes of
operations right I'm going to refer to
these things as groups and non groups
from now on which is mathematically
incorrect but you know for the sake of
the presentation just bear with me
now let's say you're trying to compute
windows over grouped operations as
you're sliding your window you have a
current value of the number of times you
visited
Indian restaurants in the last year so
if you're trying to compute the same
thing for the next day right you can
basically add what entered the window
and remove what left the window when I
say remove this is the reversibility
right and use that to produce the next
value so instead of looking at all
events in the window you can just look
at the head and the tail so you can
create the next value in constant time
right now let's say you're trying to
compute the other feature which is what
is your spice tolerance or what is the
spiciest food do you have had in the
last month so let's say the green bar
over there is what spans the window that
you're trying to consider and clearly
four is the maximum here now if you're
trying to compute the same feature the
next day right four just left the window
so to recompute what is the maximum in
the window you have to go over all the
elements in the window that's that's a
nave algorithm right but you're
essentially aggregating over roughly the
same set of elements so maybe there is
something you can do to cleverly
optimize this sliding so what we are
saying here is that we're going to break
this problem down into subproblems that
are represented by a binary roll-up so
you are going to aggregate data from
adjacent nodes all the way until it's
just one so the reason for doing that is
that now you no longer have to look at
the all the leaf nodes you can just look
at the nodes that span the window right
so this makes the whole thing tractable
so let's say you have a million events
in the window all right
namely you would have to scan million
events but with this you can basically
scan about 14 events right and that's
about that's a huge reduction in the
amount of time it takes to compute
aggregates now the time complexity
really here is quadratic versus you know
logarithmic and space so we are trading
off space for this we are actually
spending more memory to get the speed up
this is just a narrow application of
aggregation in the sense that only
windowed non groups are what actually
need these three trick everything else
can be accumulated or done the first
approach now this really is a tiling
problem so you are trying to tile the
window with the nodes that span the
window and I'd remember the three nodes
that we selected so there is some logic
that goes into selecting those and that
can be done recursively by finding a
split point that is aligned to the
powers of two and recursively going left
and right but we chose the binary tree
for a reason because this is amenable to
bit manipulations so you can find the
split point as a closed form equation
and you can so there is a proof that
basically says the tiling is the binary
representation of the distance of the
right and the left bound is to the split
point so this is all very hand wavy we
are going to write a paper and it will
be less hand wavy in the paper but so
there is another reason why
reversibility matters so let's say
you're dealing with change data change
data is data that comes from database
operations so inserts deletes and
updates so inserts are easier to deal
with but a deletion is a reversal right
and an update is nothing but a deletion
followed by an insertion so deletion of
the old value followed by insertion of a
new value so let's take the third
example which is let's say suddenly
there is a heatwave forecast at 7:00
p.m. so this will change the probability
with which you will you know choose
Indian food over other food right so in
this case you want to update and
aggregates or reverse out the last
forecast and update the next one so
concretely you have a log of queries so
you have a user you have a time at which
you want to predict certain features
about the certain attributes about the
user and you have features that are
that need to be joined together with the
time property in the sense that the
features are not too stale and not from
the future right so this is the temporal
join of the time series join that we are
talking about and if you see the left
side is the query log the right side is
the raw data and output is a joint thing
and the key observation here is that
with those properties that we discussed
about aggregations before you can do all
of this in a single pass right so you
can basically fuse the join and
aggregation together right and another
observation here is that raw data is
much much larger than the query log
itself so you would never train over
billions of events you probably trained
over hundreds of thousands or even
millions but raw data can go up to
trillions of events now this is the Tri
merge again it's a subtle difference
from what we already saw so these are
the time spans that you're trying to
generate the features for and a new
event comes in so this event is going to
affect certain queries from the future
so if an event happens right now if I
visit Indian food place right now I'm
going to increment the count for the
window of queries that happen or the
next year or the next month right so
when this comes in I am just going to
figure out which nodes to update instead
of all the queries in the window and
update just those and at the end of the
algorithm collapse all of these events
into time stamps so this is what makes
this algorithm tractable from quadratic
so a little bit about the query topology
itself you have the query log and you
grew by so the grew by here is a sort of
compression of the data that you are
going to utilize for aggregation so what
I mean by that is you're going to
broadcast the smaller data to the raw
data because raw data is larger and you
don't want to move that
so from there on you apply the tree
trick to compute the partial aggregates
and then you exploit them out across
different machines by this point the
cardinality of this of the things that
you're trying to compute is reduced from
the size of raw data to the size of
query log right now you shuffle and
merge them so at this point it's much
cheaper to move data so there are
clearly like three logical stages which
is compressing the data and broadcasting
it then joining and aggregating at the
same time and then shuffling it to the
next stage right so we are exploiting
all the three intuitions here which is
you can split aggregations arbitrarily
and the size disparity between query and
the raw data now there are several
nuances to this thing so when we use
timestamp it's not just a single
timestamp usually there are two
timestamps the time at which your system
saw the event and the time that is
contained in the event itself let's say
I try to predict or compute the number
of people who are born in the last 30
days right as a new user I just signed
up right so my event time is going to be
my birth date but my ingestion time is
going to be today right and the tree
hand is this cue but you can be more
efficient if you can use the assumption
that event time and the injection time
are same right and there are many
sources of raw data we just discussed a
single joint but you can join all of all
different sources at once more in paper
obviously all right and the next thing
we will look at is the feature serving
stack right now we have computed
features that are point in time correct
so in some sense they are offline but
you know real-time according to the
query
so there are several considerations for
future serving the first one is latency
you want to optimize wherever you're
going to put these features for point
queries so you want to get the features
of a particular key really quickly and
you want to consider two things which is
data freshness is which basically means
how recently have you written the data
and latency latency is how quickly can
you read your data now remember we
talked about change data change data is
so the way we have built it is as a
lambda architecture and lambda
architecture means that we use a little
bit of batch processing and stream
processing to produce aggregates we
haven't done Kappa for one reason Kappa
is basically using just streaming events
to produce feature aggregates what
prevents us from doing that is the fact
that there we are handing change data
change data has deletions right and if
you cannot handle deletes in real time
you will need to somehow correct from
time to time right and that's where
batch correction comes into play here so
the architecture so what we have looked
at so far is how we go from feature
declaration to a feature backfill which
feeds into model training right now the
next part is going to be about creating
the serving store or the feature store
so we compute some batch aggregates and
some streaming updates to it and put
together both the updates in a feature
store right and this all comes together
in a model server so there is a model
server that you know has a future client
that talks to the model and spits out
predictions now this is all happening in
bighead and what users see is just the
endpoint that talks to the application
server and this is what I mean by
declaration so there is just one
declaration or a few declarations that
produce this pipelines for all the users
across the companies and they can just
embed the endpoints in the application
server
right so we're going to talk about how
the data is laid out within the storage
so what we do here is the the head of
the events is basically all streaming
and the tail is coming from bash
computation so let's say you're trying
to compute 30 day window the blue box is
the first block blue boxes are coming
from batch and the green box is being
updated in real-time through streaming
and at the end the client is going to
put all of this together so the blue
boxes are of different colors for a
particular reason
so as you slide your window you want the
30 day window accuracy right so what
this means is that you cannot store a
collapsed partial aggregate in the tail
of your window but there is a problem
with this so every day you have to keep
uploading batches of the tails of the
window now the problem is if you want to
keep this available as you compute new
batch right you are going to have to
wait and that reduces the availability
of features what we just do is like add
a buffer in the tail of ROI events which
is the light blue box and the 29 days in
between is what's collapsed into a
single value and the green thing is also
a single value so as you slide to the
next day you still have some buffer so
that you can keep the system available
for the next day so one consideration
here is that the tail can be pretty
large but since these are values that
can be arbitrarily aggregated you can
reduce the resolution by collapsing them
into 15-minute buckets if you choose to
when the data is pretty large now before
we talk about the API that are the
declarations that produce all of this
let's talk a little bit about typical
data architecture in a company so that
the API makes more sense so
you start with a service fleet that is
talking to a production database all
right this is what an application stack
kind of looks like very simplified and
you create a message bus that is the
event stream that is flowing through the
services which becomes an event log in
the data like that you can access at a
later point in time and similarly with
the changes to production databases you
have a change capture stream that you
can read and aggregate over and a mirror
of this will be the change captured log
so imagine you took the beam logs from
your database and dumped it into a data
lake and partition it by day right there
is one more kind of data which is the
database snapshot itself so typically
you use tools like scoop or whatever to
produce snapshots at a certain rate
within your data X right and then there
is external data derived data and then
there is media so there are two classes
of data here the first one is events and
the second one is state all right so the
difference here is that at every point
in time you have an understanding of
what the state of the world is and the
way in which you see changes are through
pairs of before and after values of the
state as changes happen right so there
are two groups of data here really
and then there is derived data which is
easier to deal with so we don't talk
much about aggregating over derived data
and as I said earlier we are only
considering structured data so no media
so there are several types of data and
so far when you interact with a feature
engineering system right these types of
data aren't exposed these are somehow
implicit in people's minds and they use
that to imperative ly say how to scan
the data so what we are saying is
actually force users to classify what is
the kind of underlying data whether it
is entity snapshots like database
changes or whatever and entity mutations
so which is basically events right so
you can put together the database
snapshots and mutations to achieve point
in time correctness instead of scanning
the entire bin log across history right
and the idea here is that we want to
encode the understanding of the users
about how data is stored into the API
and this helps us to scan Windows
differently so here is a quick example
of how this API looks like so you're
giving a query which selects the data
that you want to scan and then you
define the operations that you want to
do over the scanned data right and you
can specify Windows and you can specify
the operation type and more there is
bucketing and whatever but we won't talk
about that so next thing that's very
important here is that you specify what
is the key so who is this person I'm
predicting whether he will have Indian
food or not and what is the time stamp
at which I am making this prediction
right time is essential to all of
ziplines so this is a must-have feature
of the data sources now to remind you so
this is what the query log looks like
and user is the key here and time stamp
is what's also selected in the query
there and then there are the aggregated
features right now you go from that
definition of an aggregation to a
training set by declaring what your
features are so you can refer to them
directly and you can select what are the
queries that you are joining against
right so that's basically my talk and
there are links of the images that I
posted before which is no proof that 95%
of the code is blue code and 50% or more
is facial engineering so thank you for
joining me today I'll take questions if
you have any
[Applause]
yeah so we use snapshots and the bin
locks for just that day to achieve you
know point in time correctness for mid
day let's say
so we try to keep the head of the window
real-time so there is no need for hourly
aggregation there but the tails are what
is reduced resolution so when I send
15-minute buckets if you have a lot of
data in the tail you want to bound it by
aggregating that into it's configurable
it's just an example so the smallest
increment is infinitesimal so you can
basically keep all the raw data to
achieve exact accuracy but if you're
okay with approximation so you can slide
over
you know hops of 15 minutes I'll take
the question from the gentleman in the
black shirt no ok so we're planning to
open source it we are actually working
in a separate repository working towards
open sourcing all of this but I don't
want to like publicly announce a
timeline I'll leave it at that
any other questions thanks a lot for
attending the talk